CHRISTOPHER SHIN: Every
time I walk into the chapel
through the front
entrance, a few steps
and you enter the main
space of the chapel.
The ceiling opens
up, and you have
the whole entire space of the
chapel comes rushing at you.
And it's an incredibly
moving and humbling feeling
to just be part of
such an open space.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the daily life
of being a student,
a lot of times our
world is very narrow.
It's very small.
It's whatever we see on our
screens or in our books.
When you enter a
space like this,
you can't help but
let your mind wander.
You can't help but --
just your heart soars
because of just the beauty
and the grandeur of this place.
I also come here often by myself
just to sit alone in the chapel
because this place is one
of the rare sanctuaries
for reverent silence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]